green am delighted to welcome Todd
Williams and Billie Tsien back as Lewis
icon visiting professors in our school
and to be able to introduce them tonight
hardly strangers in our midst as they
first offered in advance in 1992 and
have returned for subsequent times since
fall 2000 in 2003 we were honored to
exhibit their work in our gallery todd
williams and billie tsien are superb
teachers with a deep commitment to
students as individuals sharing with
them an exploration of the craft and the
composition of architecture they are
eloquent with words but their real
poetry is in the exploration of
materials and matter the work of
Williams and Chen stands apart from the
noise and early burley of so much
contemporary practice the intensity of
the approach of their approach makes
each Williams and Chen building special
but their's is not only an architecture
of craft and detail there's a
site-specific and program specific their
buildings are strong but they are also
subtle todd williams and billie tsien
are longtime collaborators in life and
in the office but they don't always see
eye to eye which makes their times
together on the platform particularly
interesting and never the same twice
they agree to disagree as they resolve
their debate while we in the audience
can benefit immensely from the exchange
of ideas todd williams is a graduate of
Princeton both that holds an
undergraduate and an architecture degree
from Princeton Billy Chen was among the
first women in the first class of women
at Yale College and then she went on to
UCLA to study architecture please join
me in welcoming todd williams and billie
tsien as they deliver the lecture last
thing
well thank you as I can't make nearly as
good a an acceptance of your gracious
offer to have his teacher and your
wonderful work as Bridget did last week
we stand it off her great lecture in the
viewer of your studio or your school and
all the work you've done here it's great
to be here thank you julie and i titled
this lasting and and i hope you last
through the entire lecture because i've
insisted that it be fairly long but i'm
in charge i'm in charge of the advanced
a clicker well when we're going to do
something a little different a couple of
recently we're asked we will show you
actually 11 projects only two of which
have just been finished all the other
projects will either be under
construction or on the boards so it's
fairly vulnerable work but when one of
the projects will show something up as
the Barnes Foundation which has received
a great deal of brouhaha and which has
been a an incredible project for us
these past few years but a reporter
asked us relatively recently what of the
Barnes Foundation this extraordinary
project was similar to the work we've
done in the past but what were the
things that tied this work to the work
in the past so we wrote down or actually
we said things to her that came out
naturally and we jotted those notes down
so that we would remember them I mean
what we're trying to do is talk about
things that are actually we realize our
lasting in our work from our earliest
work you know to the present and the
first one is the desire for permanence
yeah when when we first started out
Billy and I only did interior work as
young architects
this is the kind of work you'll get when
you when you leave Yale I think that in
the New York there's plenty of it it's
great there's always an interior that's
being torn down for but rarely a new
building and we love that work and it
was great work and it wasn't until
really the age of least meeting in my
early 40s that we got to do our very
first freestanding building a dormitory
at Princeton and we had done before that
fashion show rooms we've done a shop
we've done traders rooms installations
and actually all of them were eventually
torn out so once we got the project at
Princeton after we had recovered from
building it we look back on that work
and we realized that it really was very
very different feeling to see something
that would live much longer than your
life they're on a campus and part of the
fabric of the campus and at that time
nearly 30 years ago we've said if we can
we want to do no more commercial work
and what I want to say is not that
commercial work is bad it isn't it's
wonderful work as interiors as wonderful
work but I want to say that deciding not
to do something is just as important as
deciding to do it and so deciding to
push away commercial work and to look
toward the institutional work with
something that really changed our lives
and we continue to look that way and we
also feel that you know and it's
certainly been said before I don't know
what is permanent but buildings that
last for a long time and that our love
for a long time are the most sustainable
buildings you could on the earth so
that's what we're hoping every time when
we do a building we'd like to think of
it as 200 year building and we've talked
an NSA years ago about slowness actually
our lives aren't slow anymore in fact
the world's pretty fast and we pledged
not use computers some 15 years ago but
of course they're part of our lives
today but I still think that slowness
plays a very important part in our work
we believe in a building that is a slow
tape
immediate take that it takes time to get
to know a person it takes time to get to
know a building and we like the layers
that that requires so that's also I
think a quality of reticence is also
something that we think about in our
work that everything is not revealed
immediately and that it takes a while to
really start to know what a building is
what our buildings are it's not it's not
meant to be fast a third I guess trait
or something that we're looking for is
this desire to in a way surrender to a
site and a program and in that way lose
ourselves in order to find ourselves and
I think that that means not just
surrounding to a site that's running to
a client I don't do it too often but
surrendering to Billy she's surrendering
to me and to one another you have to in
a way in order to really get to know
something really to go deep I think you
actually have to let go and and that is
the way of getting to know a site and
getting to know the program the next
subject you looking at me for some
reason move along no no I'm trying to
surrender no I'm looking at you because
I'm listening to okay
we we've titled this next one wait and
digging in I would I've come to believe
that the ground the surface on which we
exist the interface between Earth and
sky is the most important plane for all
of us it's place from which we are born
and where we return it's based its
mother earth and it's the difference
between Earth and sky and I want to say
that I think that heavy buildings are
good buildings this is a heavy building
it demands its weight it accepts its
place it's a serious work and I believe
that it bores into the ground and it
rises up from the ground and it
recognizes the importance of the thick
wall the heavy wall the sort of need to
get give something that lasts I also
want to say sorry that I think that on a
campus the most important surface we
have on a campus is the bat of this
course it's the plane that connects the
buildings together it's the quadrangle
it's the street it's the walk and as one
moves up or down from that you're always
moving away from the most important
plane in our lives so I want to take
that very seriously and recognize that
it's easy to go down a level and easy to
go up a level and it's hard to go up 10
or 15 levels despite the fact that we do
that this building has fortunately a
series of important interior spaces that
feel like there's contacted with the
ground plane another issue is a
designing really from the inside out we
really believe and you know maybe it is
because we started out doing so many
interiors that we all know the majority
of our lives are lived inside and we
believe in the the power and the
intimacy of the interior experience very
much as we sort of believe in the power
of the interior of people so the shells
of course you know express what's going
on but it's really
the interior that is the most important
and then i'd also i say even in that
subject we should also say that's why
materials are mean a lot I mean it
because these are the things that are
most intimate to us it's easier to touch
the inside or a piece of wood of a space
than it is really to go up and touch the
outside so the just that's once again
the way we are as humans and then the
final one that we wanted to talk about
is as evolution I think that our work
basically always accepts where it came
from and it's always interested in where
it goes but it doesn't forget its past
and I think we can never forget our past
that we take with us the baggage of what
we've done before and I think the only
way we can really grow effectively is to
be able to personally critique the or
work of course it's critiqued by others
and that sometimes is painful because
there's truth and there's lies in that
but we need to look honestly at the work
and we need to use that as a springboard
to move forward and to us we will see
themes as we look through our work will
see themes that we pick up we've made a
mistake we once or twice it's a good
mistake we try not to make it the next
time if we have success we try to come
back to that success and find out what
made it a success not just to recreate
it okay so we're going to start now
you're in charge nope
I gave you the pointer okay it's okay no
no it's okay I got it oh he's okay good
thank you got the point okay go okay 11
projects as fast as we can go and Todd's
going to tell me to go back but I may or
may not so these three built projects
the last one only recently completed not
really moved into the east asian library
at Berkeley we may have shown this
before but it's right in the center of
the Berkeley campus and it was a
building that took many many years to
get done this is not our building but
because and its site changed three times
with the politics of Berkeley but it was
worth this the contents are East Asian
text so it faces dough and that's what
you see up on top which is the main
library of the campus and they wanted a
building that was imposing and also in
some way made a reference to the
neoclassical classicism of dough well
the same time that clay tile ruse a
symmetrical facade vertical stone or
basically white white stone or granite
at the same time the books inside our
only character language books japanese
chinese and korean so although we needed
to create a symmetrical facade because
that was part of our rules we made an
asymmetrical facade which is really
hidden behind this screen it's a south
facing screen made of cast bronze panels
57 of them which were sand cast in china
and then we're assembled and they do
with a perforated metal mesh
it's quite a good sunscreen you can
actually walk behind them to clean the
windows but the facade behind is
different now this is a four-story
building and you enter strangely rather
than on access here from the side
because this is the north gate
passageway and we are also trying to
negotiate a very steep slope that goes
from north to south here so you're
really entering at the third level which
means that you can cross over from the
top of the hill or you're walking up
stairs are taking an elevator this is
that a drive that will eventually become
a more dignified surface but you can see
that this is the walk that extends to
the hill steps that tumble down from a
kind of an element vertical element that
speaks a little bit to say their tower
but here is our building just directly
or not directly but close to being
directly opposite doe library so it
brings to the character languages which
are critical in Berkeley a kind of
parallel or comparable dignity to that
of the East the Western languages but
it's really a box for books it's a very
quiet very solid box for books but
inside it's split open by light so the
inside i think is a great surprise for
people who walk in because it feels very
very open there's a light sort of
opening a shaft that really divides the
building in half brings light from the
top to the bottom and it's a light
that's ever-changing it is always saw
never direct largely however these are
these are stacks for research
researchers they're not so many people
although people have come to like to sit
and study there even those who are not
looking at East East Asian texts the
stairway as is typical with us is the
primary means of movement although
there's an elevator and that never
varies it I mean it always varies it's
never stacked on top of one another it's
always used to be to encourage people to
use their
their legs in their senses as they move
vertically to the building the back of
the building faces north so one looks
out to the more natural California
hillside and this is from the reading
room which is on the third floor from
there you ascend the stairs to the top
floor from the inside you see the grid
but you also are looking through
perforated metal so it's cutting down
the amount of sunlight but the light
does drop from top to bottom there are
quite in contemplative places we had no
budget for art the building was as where
the building is stone on the outside its
concrete on the inside where it's
concrete on the outside it's actually
sheetrock on the inside so because of
the weather barriers so what we did is
Billy had the rather brilliant idea of
taking walk off mats that cost five
hundred dollars each and our 20 feet
long and inkjet printing images from the
books in the library on to those so they
become both a kind of sound absorbent
surface and also an area of light and
brightness in fact a replacement for the
art that they can't really put in a
library and although we didn't design
the chairs we decided all the tables
library furniture in the lamps this is
an interior space that's my water I have
a cold and it's a tiny interior space of
T shaped space it was a privately owned
public space which is a way that
developers in New York City were able to
build taller buildings because they
needed to create they created spaces
that were open to the public but this
one had really deteriorated most of the
pup of these pops as they call them are
not very well used spaces so this was
the before in Lincoln Center as as part
of its revitalization plan saw that this
was a neighbor and they decide
even though they don't own the space
that they would take this space and
renovate it and use it as a kind of
front porch for them so it's really due
to their generosity that all of this
project occurred so from 1979 to
basically 2010 this space had been used
but only marginally there was a climbing
wall and otherwise largely it was a
place for homeless and people would
sleep in the space but the reason they
wanted it if at the far end of the space
is actually Lincoln Center so this is a
space that bridges between broadway and
columbus with little side entrance on
sixty-second street and and so we simply
excavated the entire interior we left
all of the structure which actually sits
in through these creating skylights
where we could this is a false skylight
but the real ones actually allow natural
light and in addition you have
artificial light that illuminates
through those then we have long panels
of materials to help to make it feel
like a comfortable place to be very tall
green walls at either end to cushion the
sound and the shock of Broadway or
Columbus a water fountain here a
performance space in the center and very
very and long felt walls on either side
murals by a friend of ours Claudia
youngstrom at tonight for example they
will target will present a concert free
of charge and so this really is a mixing
spot for many people in the neighborhood
so the doors are 15 feet tall and on
good nights not tonight they'll open up
and you can see it's a kind of upside
down carpet you know that takes you
right through this is the Broadway side
to the other side they also this is
where they will sell I don't know if
Todd mentioned lower price tickets the
day of performance to all of the venues
at Lincoln Center so it's been
enormously popular
and and it's great to be able to make a
public space in New York it's not itself
iconic it's rather a place to be rather
than an object so these are cloudy's
felt tapestries the stone walls this is
actually our air conditioning grill and
large stone benches that are made of a
stone that's very Chinese being green
stone that's not dissimilar to the
tapestry of the plant will actually
really increasing the sense of freshness
to the space so we really wanted to make
sense of a kind of interior garden and
they do live streaming from performances
at Lincoln Center here's what I've
cloudy young strands helpers putting
final touches on these pieces she's a
very interesting artists Dutch and has
worked with a lot of architects and she
raises her own sheep shears them makes
natural dyes from plants and then
creates these pieces this actually comes
from the drawing at Todd dude fountain
the ability to change the lights and
then the third of the built work just
being completed now it's a house in
amagansett a very large house and but
the principles of the planning
principles I think are useful even if
we're not going to look really at the
interior it's basically a solid base
with a glass top this is a very early
sketch and they wanted a large house
this is a family with three grown
daughters a two acre site and actually
no view of the ocean whatsoever and the
they also had a number of friends so we
created a pavilion in the center with a
hole in it this is a glass pavilion and
then it is supported on one two three
supports which are a garage a guest
house and
the family unit and then there's an
outdoor living space through here in
gardens to be developed we wanted to
make sure that as you walk you look
through this Center cruciform of space
you would always look to nature you
would not see the cars that are
necessary to drive to the house so it is
a very simple plan this is the guest
structure which could be its own small
home two bedrooms and a little shared
living room a garden the garage and
support through there an outdoor dining
area and as we've said as I've said
earlier a kitchen dining living and then
the three girls rooms the glass pavilion
is the master bedroom and study but
largely a kind of an attic space so the
building is made of stone stone blocks
that it's that are two feet long and
three inches thick so it's all solid
stone and wood windows on the lower
level and a glass rather reflective to
keep the heat out element on the top
which has cuts in it to allow
ventilation so in fact cross ventilation
is very very easy in this house that
sketch of the master bedroom which
really extends in a kind of donut shape
around the top the roofs will be planted
in the next few and then the next
month's as green roofs but this is the
center space this kind of public space
in the walls then hide gardens and allow
you not to see the neighbor this is a
driveway that goes by to a neighbor's
house but to look at nature from the
pool and this is an outdoor living space
temporary chairs in the in the dining
room there this is the beginning of the
outdoor living space more of that
the vestibule to the guest room we don't
have furniture in here at this point but
there's a tree in the garden one of the
guest bedrooms and their repeat using
concrete walls to sort of screen the
landscape and create gardens inside
gardens they will also frame small slot
views of the landscape these four
projects are projects that are really in
design right now the first one is that n
langer Center which is a building for
nano technology Study at Princeton it's
a very large building and a rather ugly
sight on the Princeton campus but many
of you don't know this campus but those
who do know that this is the engineering
quadrangle this is old and street and
then Prospect Street rather good garage
by Machado and so savetti a less
wonderful building by Ellen chimacum
Owen hall but this is all the
engineering complex and this that it's
actually surrounded by a wall a very
beautiful wall which we have said is
something we wanted to keep the this the
engineering study here is Billy says
isn't largely done in labs in clean labs
it's a place where one uses a tremendous
amount of energy at the same time it's
just the step for the study of the
environment so we had a kind of
conundrum here of what did it mean to
study the environment as even as you in
a way polluted the environment through
the incredible production of clean rooms
we decided to keep the walled garden
through here and then in fact create a
series of gardens on the interior
dropping the buildings down into the
ground and making sure that nothing was
more than three stories tall the campus
level i would say goes right through the
site and we can
wander through the site just as you do
any campus today on on grade then
there's a garden level which connects
three lower level gardens I go back
Billy okay a garden level which connects
this garden to this garden to this
garden so that people who are working at
the lower levels are always looking to
light from their study areas and then a
level which connects the entire main
level of the engineering quadrangle to
the building so there are three
overlapping paths it's a very
complicated building very hard to
understand which basically what we're
trying to do is press everything down
and make them surround well you're the
crew of the earth we're using many many
devices which will allow the fresh air
that's used in the laboratories to pass
through such places as a classroom or
conference room and then to be reused as
we then cool it further into the last
we're using first the cooling of the of
the earth where there are many devices
here that I think are have remarkable
energy savings but there are also some
very simple ones that we will see later
the idea of naturally ventilating this
conference room we've seen before we're
working with trans solar so that I think
we have very very sophisticated systems
in the building and very logical systems
this is an upper level path let's say to
connect Bowen Hall through our building
to the e-way and and then crude sketches
of the power this is a ventilation tower
at the same time it is vertical
circulation and this vertical
circulation is actually a fire exit so
as has been done on other projects the
circulation is never that a fire stair
is always a public stair and in this
case the tower actually is used to
exhaustion vent
the material that needs to be sent high
up into the sky this is the e wing or
the campus level this apartment this is
the engineering level that's one level
above grade this is the campus level
we're standing on and then this is the
lower level research labs down here
working with Michael Van Valkenburg
these will be very very lush gardens
we're continuing to think and develop
them but we want them to be destination
so that people want to go to the lower
levels and we can see a path here let's
say from the clean rooms which really
seem to want no connection to the
outdoors through the gardens through a
public passageway here along the hallway
and then across diagonally to the
conference center at the other side
there could be other paths so this is a
second of the three primary courtyards
and this one you can see has a very
different sense than the first one which
Michael was imagining we could expose
the bedrock and and this one is much
more seasonal like the house this one is
made of massive walls with in this case
actually as the base of the house
they're relatively few windows but
windows carefully placed so that they
bring like where we need it for example
flat skylights that bring light into
research spaces here which we then use
cool cool ceilings and actually have
cross ventilation and then a view from
one actually the research level costs of
a pond here one of the things that we
produce is way too much heat so if we
have a pool of water and this is a very
high water level will be able to
actually keep a warm pool here
throughout the winter here we're looking
at the comfort zone so you really enter
a garden this is actually from street
level that's the corner of prospect and
olden people walking around and finding
different ways to get
into this lower level even as they cross
through in the campus level and then
accident metric of the site of the
building which I really will disappear
as an earlier idea is that it's not a
building it's really garden walls series
of gardens another project is her the
opposite end of size it's tiny it's a
little little project up in New
Hampshire which we're really happy to
have at the mcdonald colony and we
interviewed and won this feel badly
because they do such amazing work from
Bridget mentored among others in
addition to this very tiny library in
New Hampshire at the mcdonald colony
it's a it's a library that's a single
room and it has many of the strengths of
a single room but many of the problems
macdowell colony is a series of tiny
dwellings that are spread out over this
incredible acreage we're largely writers
could come in these very very simple
hand built structures they wanted to
make sure that the buildings felt like
they were local in fact they insisted
that we use the local carpenter who is
made or repaired all of these buildings
so this is a very different kind of
assignment architects go there too this
is the library which is around 100 years
old and which is a single room
unfortunately the dork and is directly
into that single room so it has no air
conditioning but they also have trouble
maintaining the books in that space and
right next to the library and in the
woods is an amazing Rock bigger than I
am and we decided our project should
like the Moby Dick a planted forest will
be thinned that's part of the context so
for as an addition we decided to restore
this small library and to make our
building everything that the library
wasn't a series of space is not a single
space where people could be but a series
of spaces where people could go in and
find some quiet conversations and work
so this is really the way we often work
which is to make a print of the building
and then to do a drawing and then print
it out and start to correct it so it's a
it's a kind of layer drawing where we
see that we might enter this is a stone
wall with glass on the corners you enter
the building under cover you walk in
through a vestibule in the wintertime
and the slight soaps lights very gently
down to go back Billy forget about okay
at any rate there are paths to find
tables to that could be put together
video study carrels places where the
collections can be stored places where
people can pick up a wreath and read a
book looking at a small pool of water
can look at the large rock outside and
so on it's in fact a pleural space where
there's many many places 30 people could
be collectively in savage library or
individually in this edition bread
[ __ ] graduate of the school is is
running this project our idea was to
leave the library as a block and to then
create a fireplace an outdoor fireplace
that would welcome people at the end of
dinner to come on over and perhaps have
a drink or two what is
the presentations that exist in the
library so the library becomes kind of a
beacon behind the stone walls and and
together these two elements create I
think much more complex and interesting
destination but here as in handling or
even though they're very different sizes
it's really the desires not to make a
building is an object really in an
lingard's try to make the building a
series of gardens and courtyards at
least perceived that way and here it's
trying to make the building a wall a
wall that sits behind their small
granite library which is for many people
at mcdowell a very important memory
piece and then the third project that
all three of these projects are really
in a schematic design is student
residences at Haverford College which I
didn't know much about him we didn't
know much about until recently we had
heard of it of course it's right next to
Bryn Mawr and outside of Philadelphia
but it turns out it's a it's also an
arboretum the campuses in arboretum and
a beautiful landscape so when we went
there we were astonished by the beauty
of the landscape the assignment was to
to create student dormitories and
carrying Timberlake had done a plan of
dormitories that would exist there and
they were three and a half storey
buildings you can see long bars like
this and this was that they also
interviewed for the project this was a
prototype that they thought would exist
and that would give 240 beds they
actually wanted more beds and we looked
at this and then analyzed it and said
what would happen if we got rid of all
stairs and elevators and made two
one-story buildings stacked on top of
one another and lo and behold and turned
out that we can actually
reduce the total square footage
massively create all of the same amount
of amenities and actually much more
because we have wonderful living rooms
and through here at better bathrooms and
places to meet the the community is a
community of 20 which we can see here
all of the students in this study had
said we will pay singles and doubles but
by the time we met them everyone wanted
a single so absolutely every single room
here is a single every bathroom when you
walk into a toilet is a complete room as
is a shower complete room there's a
kitchen and a little living room through
here at laundry and that an interior
courtyard so this is the first level of
a two-story building where it bearing
block building and and with brick
exterior in order to do it basically
took and they will also be entirely
green roofs on these two buildings we
took and created a very very large berm
we'll see something like this a little
later in our work in Mumbai but we
basically made a berm which is 11 feet
tall where you gently walk up onto the
top of the Burma or send steps walk
across it and continue through to other
buildings these two will be the first
will make and and we're even connect
between the two buildings so once again
this is an idea of buildings which are
really not visible as buildings they're
intended to disappear into the landscape
be places to be well they're also using
the landscape as really the circulation
all vertical circulation takes place
outside couple of these little crude
sketches to give them a sense of what
we're talking about poured-in-place
concrete walls brick buildings very very
simple wooden windows actually wonderful
wooden windows and this is one of the
bridges that connects the upper level
campus level to that and the lower
levels is crossed this way yes as I cut
through the jewel
here we're looking at this wonderful
brick actually that this first thought
of I developed with peter zumthor but
these are new versions of it that are
made in Germany actually adding stand to
the exterior of the brick and adding
salt to the exterior of the brick and
we're studying these different long
bricks they actually can now make a much
longer brick which means the brick is
itself expensive but laying it is less
expensive so these are laid up in a in a
random fashion or an apparent random
fashion and then once again sort of
facade where you see essentially it's
set down and there are two levels of
circulation this is a project for a
skating rink in prospect park in
brooklyn this the themes are continuing
to sort of stacked on top of one another
once again to one story building this is
Wolman rink in Prospect Park we set on
an absolutely beautiful olmsted inbox
site the music grove in a terrible
building and a terrible destruction of
Olmstead inboxes landscape this has
always been a carriage drive and now as
the surface for 300 cards our idea is to
restore as it's happening right now the
entire Olmsted and box music growth and
take this facility and put it on this
surface essentially warping once again
the photography so that you walk on and
over that building hardly noticing it so
here you can see the original drawing
and you can see the carriage concourse
and that is as Todd said where the
skating rinks will be well this is where
they will be this is where they are
right now so music Island will be
restored this whole edge will be
restored concert grove restored and we
will make that these to this facility
which will replace this one and here's
the rink so so unfortunately in the
summertime this rink is that really just
used for is just left barren
and of course it's not covered by
anything our idea is to cover it with a
very very large canopy so that you can
that snow won't fall on it rain won't
fall out is the kind of calligraphy on
the canopy will talk about these are
asymmetrical stone columns that support
it at the perimeter and then a long
mural Billy is done through here we're
basically not noticing that you've
walked up onto this surface because
there's no evidence to that if you want
from the other side nor is there any
evidence that you're walking into a
building here so here we have the cafe
and here we have this end bony and over
here we have the skate rental and so on
if there are really two rinks one is a
regulation hockey rink and that's the
one that's underneath this roof and
another one is a more freeform rink and
that's out in the open and in the summer
time they will transform to freeform
rink will be water play and this will be
the rollerskating films or whatever this
is a winter depiction where the hockey
rink is joined together with the preform
ring so they can be used together they
can then at various times be separated
so this city under the canopy operates
on its own this operates it on its own
and then there's a heavily vegetated
green roof over the top once again from
the sky there will be really only a very
small portion of hardscape that's
visible we'll be making this of granite
we tried to make it of the shifts that
they're drilling the tunnels that the
new tunnels the second Avenue subway
from but they are grinding that material
up would have been great to use just in
this and a depiction of walking in
another one you buy your tickets here
undercover you continue through in this
place this is this is this mural will
see in a moment this is actually a
skating surface that one can walk on the
skates these are tiles that Billy is
working with Heath from Sausalito we
worked with them before to create a kind
of a a hand dipped I'll that is varied
so
the idea is to create a winter winter
summer blend over 150 feet this if all
the tiles are made of single colors in
this if they're blurred colors we're
working on the two different ones the
ceiling and then the view from that
upper level the ceilings taken from
mechanical idea of fake the figure and
movement and the skate and movement and
they will be interspersed these will
both be there will be a series of lights
that light the space adequately for
hockey but then there will also be this
calligraphy that is is etched deeply
into the ceiling
okay and the first project is at
Bennington colleges it's an interesting
program where they would like to invite
people to come and talk at Bennington
give seminars stay there for a few days
so the program is a kind of dialogue
centre where they're both classrooms and
offices but primarily a large seminar
room and then also the program is a
place for people to stay for a few days
so it's their series of small residences
and then there's a small building that's
a kind of off the grid building which is
a mark on template of space I mean I
should say that all of the buildings
were going to see her at least leed gold
or platinum this one this building is
entirely off the grid these are
residences back here and then this is
the building that Billy called a kind of
seminar building but there are three
individual one-story building we'll talk
about them they're also on a very gentle
sloping landscape and they're under
construction now here we are standing
citing the buildings that's Billy and me
and so I don't what the hell we're
finding out no no it doesn't that's the
receipt level that's the ground level
yeah that's this is what we think about
this is what the ground level will be
that's correct so we reshape the land
very slightly to come up to this is the
ground level we're reconnecting this
there's a beautiful potentially a
beautiful pond that we're restoring and
then we're also changing the back of a
wonderful but very ugly building called
vapid visual and performing arts center
so here is the complex it's our three
buildings this is the residential
building you actually have a front porch
through here and you can walk through it
there are six residents is in this
building they can be joined together to
make three each of them will be
furnished uniquely this is the main
building which is a place where the
students can use this building 24 7
have a large seminar space in this
faculty lounge in the space and a series
of smaller seminar spaces and this is
another building which is this building
is the one that's off the grid we can
either call it a spiritual retreat or
itself kind of seminar room well as you
saw in the house in amagansett and
really in our older work we're very
interested in pulling apart the program
and then thinking about the spaces in
between the program this these are
actually the plans actually the porch so
the students can literally walk through
the residence or walk between these two
buildings but these are this is a
grouping of two rooms with a living room
so it could be two apartments this is
another two apartments in the
neighborhood another one so there's one
two three or six of them that 100 person
seminar space through here faculty
lounge through there this is where
students work at whatever hour they wish
to think about their turma as they leave
school there's a place where the
students leave school in the middle of
winter to go out and serve their
community a seminar room here and then
this is another seminar room I should
also say that courtyard serves as a
seminar room so you can see one two
three rather clear of seminar rooms and
the so the center of the building is
this void bringing light to the interior
the building it will be all translucent
glass when we went to Vermont it's very
interesting Vermont has huge abandoned
marble quarries marble would they had
some of the largest marble quarries
certainly in the united states that were
active until the saw the diamond saw was
invented and they could start to cut
granite at which point the entire marble
industry died so we went to these marble
and yards and they're kind of like
marble gram yards where large pieces of
marble didn't do that
but well from numbers at different
quarries have been left basically they
can't do anything with this Marvel so we
said will you give it to us free well
they didn't but they gave it to his in a
very low cost and there are six
different marbles that are scattered
around here and we simply went through
with a guy with a saw and said let's use
these pieces and he said we'll have to
create a system so this is a mock-up
we're working on that the buildings have
moved along but it's amazing this is
only 50 miles from from Bennington we
eventually laid out all the facades in a
gymnasium nearby so that we could get
something that felt that could handle
the grills that were necessary in the
windows that were necessary but created
some sort of a a positive pattern on the
facade it's kind of both the hidden
pattern and a positive time we did this
because the marble was so varied we
couldn't really leave it to chance
because you could end up with a really
white patch and a really dark patch so
every facade was laid out fully dry laid
out in this warehouse and in the end I
think it really helped Mason's because
it was labeled remember what it up yeah
dried all the Marvel out it was done
during the wintertime and then they were
able to label it simply put it right up
on the building so it's now been glad
this is a early sketch of that little
seminar space we wanted to be like our
pool at cranbrook in this case we
because it's off the grid supposedly you
hand crank the roof open if it rains it
rains into a stone floor you can meet in
a space and by using the Sun to strike
come in from the south strike the
surface it can tend to give some warmth
to a space that otherwise it's basically
not heated this it's a steel frame all
of the buildings of steel frame
buildings this is that space last winter
we have this wonderful person who's
created that hand gearing is done a lot
of from the Pacific Northwest to create
actually the gears that will allow this
to be turned by any person so that's
filter it's kind of a a toy i should say
but it'll be a useful toy and this now
moot has just been installed and it
moves smoothly completely out of the way
like a double drawer spotify and many
buildings which will be amazing i think
both in the green but also in the snow
when it's when it's white and also on
those many many great days and in the
vermont same facade that you saw and all
of the sort of various devices are set
within niches that have a black stone as
a backing so it very very strongly
sensitive so these buildings once again
i intended just to be lines in the
landscape this is the seminar room
actually looking at the wall of the
residences rather than looking at it's
very tight and then there's also a
pattern where the stones are pulled in
so that it both varies in color but it
also varies in plain well as the Sun
strikes the building and changes from
one plane to the next it has a nice
little calligraphy once again wooden
windows project in hong kong that's been
going on since 2001 where we won this
competition for what we said was a
horizontal garden in a vertical City and
this is the building and the building is
actually joining this landscape to this
landscape to this building there are
four heritage buildings on the site and
to Heritage berms and we're right in the
center of the tallest buildings in Hong
Kong but it's intended being in biz
building here it is you're looking down
from the chamber lot of power onto the
roof of the building under construction
and you can show the Noah the Nullah
that runs through this i can ever
surging water course that runs right
through the site these buildings were
made by the British in 1840 this one a
berm this was for making munitions this
was a berm to make sure that when they
were stored in this space and this
exploded this wouldn't explode there
would be another berm through here in
another storage space and rail cars
would connect all of these so we wanted
to preserve and reuse these which we're
doing this will be a museum a theater
and seminar spaces then we also wanted
to connect this by a path under shade
and undercover to a garden roof through
here and then descend into our building
so these are that one of the munitions
buildings that is made into a museum
look at that the cupboard passageways
that you have to walk under so the rain
just and the Sun don't sort of knock you
out but here you can see it is a very
horizontal building this is an early
rendering of the actually competition
run into the project this is as we end
it from below right opposite the British
Consulate this wall will be covered in
green it's that black granite this is a
heritage building will be covered in
time and mrs. actually our building so
our building is very very horizontal
here thus and then the interior of the
munition space which we will try to
expose as much as possible even as we
hang out of the walls this is the cut
this is a roof plan of this route that
runs along pathway and also below it
actually are the tracks that they used
to run the small cards that would hold
the black powder and they would then put
these cards on
kind of monorail and run them down too
so this is a little bit of a Chinese
garden path you can see the rails are
being inserted back again and into the
stone floor these walls are existing
walls and this is the canopy that we've
created that moves kind of chinese
garden path through the landscape always
giving the protection it actually now
continues through this very very strong
cut in the landscape now at this point
and then it continues across the Nullah
with a bridge which is below and a
bridge which is above so this will all
be very very is already all now tree
planted and becomes jungle very soon
this will be a completely planted garden
as this will be embedded in the
landscape soon and we're on a garden
roof so the idea and again is to let the
buildings disappear into the landscape
we use the kind of green stone from from
China that enhances the idea that that
these are intended to disappear in part
of the landscape yeah so this is a upper
terrace which hasn't obviously been
planted yet so now there are two more
projects and they're both what lead
larger projects this is the Barnes
Foundation that's usually my line this
is Albert Barnes who collected Master
amazing collection of paintings he did
this with a fortune that was made by a
medicine that he produced and the site
for the this collection was in a house
that he had a museum that he built for
himself in Marion and moving moving to
the Benjamin Franklin Parkway which is
downtown to this site I mean the
controversy of the move is huge this is
a building by Paul crane sits in an
arboretum and there are other outlying
buildings
whether this actually was Barnes house
and there's of course great
consternation that this is leaving this
area but Barnes was a complex man and
there were provisions that enabled
although he said this should never leave
the building must always be hunt as it
is the problem is in the late 1990s they
were losing five hundred thousand
dollars a year it was a big problem and
eventually solved at least some of us
would say by moving it downtown bars was
weird because you can see here he really
hated intellectuals and he believed that
art should be taught not to could be
taught to anyone by looking at very very
simple principles of lime plain color
and so on so he was very famous for
keeping people out who he thought were
people that you know morons boobs
professional exploiters general
counterfeits Yale graduates anyway this
is the plan of the existing barnton and
in order for us to to to gain this this
commission we had to agree to the
judge's ruling that all of the works
would stand on the walls as they are so
what did it turn out to be well it
turned out to be an incredibly
interesting problem we thought okay
we're lumber by we replicating every one
of these
rooms and law says that we must do that
the piece of hardware you can see that
Barnes would cite his paintings
bilaterally symmetrical II in spaces he
would stack them so on style but then he
would intersperse them with elements of
hardware that he had collected he
polished and there are many many people
who say that this is not only not only
did he collect many terrible paintings
but many counterfeits himself because he
was learning about this nonetheless
they're just extraordinary paintings
here the postman and that have been seen
by very few people because these are the
kinds of people i guess like us today go
to the bar so it's a really elite place
and moving in downtown was a way by
which we believe and many of us believe
that this can be seen as Barnes wanted
to buy a whole different kind of public
this in fact was what we presented when
we were presenting our competition well
we were trying to there was a small sort
of mini competition and we try to be
very clear because none of the people
who are looking at the work for
architects and we said look the existing
building is a gallery in a garden and we
would like to put this garden bring the
sense of a garden into this new gallery
and we said that because of course it
was an arboretum but we also said it
because everyone but three of the
windows in the existing building had
been closed off from the garden the
light being too invasive and yet all of
it are in the in the collection is
impressionist that has so much to do
with the garden so we we hope that we
could reinsert gardens in the building
we also brought this little toy love
which really had some has some
credibility today but is very different
which is to say that we would take the
bearing walls and drop spaces in this is
a very wallet today joins that very well
if we cut the plan directly through here
we can put a classroom in and we can put
a garden in the building and those
give a place to rest your eyes and maybe
to think or to learn Barnes was very
much interested in education and that
would help to keep the ensemble impact
but also to give relief this is the site
plan I should say that we I won't
explain it too much more except to say
the building is relatively small in this
space and it's our desire that we have
to leave the car behind and walk through
a garden actually a rather long way to
get into the building and into the
collection the intention being to drop
your shoulders in a way how the garden
take precedence even if we're on the
mall so there's been some controversy as
to why we didn't enter our building this
way well there were lots of good reasons
we felt certainly one of them was that
this there would be no cushion from the
Benjamin Parkway but furthermore this
particular facade faces south also faces
south in Marion with collection it but
this is a landscape plan drawn by Laurie
Olin where we're preserving a triple row
of London pain plane trees adding a
large pool at the entrance which would
be for any of the citizens of
Philadelphia a very small drop off for
cars the parkland that they so sorely
need and then a kind of series of walled
gardens that protect the experience
Barnes had a very large collection of
African art which is part of his what he
shows what is shown in the gallery
spaces we were very interested in
textiles and so this there's a kind of
idea of a tapestry or textile use of
stone as a facade and one that would
also incorporate some metal in it
because there's a sense certainly in all
the compositions he makes using sort of
decorative pieces of metal much have
your phone
he thought it was the right color and
the Negev in southern Israel actually
went to the quarry as we always do here
actually I don't know I was able to
split a rock once they did ninety
percent of the for me but anyway we're
using this stone called ramon gray and
we're then using it in a variety of
different finishes this is an early mock
up with a bronze blade at stainless
steel back up and then the panel's
themselves that are set to create a rain
screen system on the facade so this is a
kind of compressed version of a lot of
different conditions so that facade
itself is not so active and so the
facade it faces the parkway is in fact
the south-facing facade with paned
windows exactly as they exist in the
galleries and only in the place in the
galleries where they just no other
windows exist on this the back-up
building which is the support structure
is an L shaped structure through which
you better in this building and this
building together support a very very
long light box and the light box is
internal here and external there this
really represents different ways by
which people can come from the north
from the south from here or from the
east in this direction this is the entry
to the gallery so as Todd said do you
really are walking through a garden just
as when you enter the existing Marian
building you're going through a garden
in that we felt that that was very very
important to the experience of seeing
the art there and and then although
there are windows is virtually hidden in
this facade mr. Renner obviously of that
rather than a drawing of the things so
the idea is maybe with Condor
grove of trees in this case you pass
over us very very shallow of body of
water into an entrance that is actually
open to the sky through a small spot
here you look straight ahead to the
garden which is in the Marian billing
these are all wood windows and then
enter the building to your right you
when you enter you don't get a ticket
you purchase the ticket before you enter
the complex so that once again it's
trying not to be commercial to have even
kind of monumental but a residential
quality this is the sketch of the light
court we the interior facades are stone
and then this carved shaped surface is a
little bit like the Berkeley building
where indirect light comes in through
the light box so if the Marian building
is as a kind of jewel box and is
representing the sort of both the
massing and the fenestration of Marian
the l-shaped building is a more abstract
very very quiet rendering of being
outside under the terrace and looking to
the road and yard were raised up a
little using the notion of a hot to get
rid of the traffic which swirls around
the site and the interior when you're
using stairs they will be made of wood
actually they'll be made of EPM this
terrible drawing stone interiors there's
a guard the garden which penetrates
through the building starts at the very
lowest level the basement level and
extends past the first level in the
second level to the sky we and then the
these are the interiors galleries these
windows historically have just since for
the last 50 years have only had a very
small view of the garden and in our new
approach we will make them wood windows
with glazing that will not will enable
people to look out to the garden so this
represents the interior today and this
something of a change i should say we
will change many other things in here
including the terrible everybody there's
an amazing painting called the joy of
life which is difficult to see today
being on a stairway that is we now are
permitted to move that great work of 19
6 by Matisse to an area directly
opposite the blueness that we just saw
so they only changes we could make are
making within the body of the gallery
other than sort of very subtle texture
old ones are ones that have to do with
accessibility so that allows us to
create a new gallery or we're making
changes with light and we're simplifying
and intensifying a lot of the molding
details so this is one of the upper yeah
Florida gallery her Gilman is the
director heat when the guards are not
iran and he has his way he lifts the
shades and allows natural light to come
in and completely change the art here so
our idea is that we don't no longer have
these shades but we filter the light at
the outside of me even though we might
keep a placebo or may not that would be
seem to be a modulator of the space the
light will come from other sources well
what we're doing is we're top lighting
every single second floor gallery right
now there are only two that are topless
so here's a top like gallery I mean an
existing gallery this is actually at the
lower level whether this is a sketch of
the joint light a light gallery where we
create apertures that are not dissimilar
from the ones that Palmer ants and Bob
and Terry created at the National
gallery but in our apertures we will see
no mullions it will be kind of more
abstract diffusion of light into the
space so the room is bathed in light
we're also then going to be able to
adjust the moldings and perhaps the
fabric here we've made a a mock-up here
that we go to every few days outside of
Philadelphia where we're testing out
plaster services and looking at the
traditional moldings and then looking at
new moldings so I've got that sort of
right hand side which replicates but
cleans up the existing condition and we
have the left hand side if I get that
wrong yeah left hand side where we're
trying to understand how to reinterpret
them I mean we know that the moldings
are very important without them I always
say that it would be like you took
shaped off your eyebrows because the
paintings are very much in sort of
relationship to each other and in
relationship to the moldings so a
requirement knows to knock down all that
fourteen percent of the light that comes
through the glass and we've been able to
do that now and look directly outside
this is the site as of a few days ago if
you built rebuilding the Marian block
quickly of Steel so that within by the
winter time it will be enclosed actually
this is an image from the lowest level
where we look right through the hole to
the sky society the library that wraps
the lower level garden this is the main
level and then this is the second level
of the building this is the last project
that we're showing tonight if you look
at the next to the last note it says
that somebody called about a large
project in India and this was a number
of years ago and we didn't take it very
seriously because there are a lot of
these kinds of calls that happen and
most of them don't really ever make any
sense especially because we've never
done a campus
we had never been India it seemed pretty
bogus so I arrived as I usually doing
with flip-flops and shorts and they had
these couple of indian guys there
waiting for us this is the site a few
months ago which is that the site is
actually on the north north to south
connector the main Western Road of India
there are changing conditions like the
hutments that exist on the outside the
campus is being used today even today
even if we're building the building and
our idea is to save every one of the
eighteen hundred trees somewhere another
so that our idea is to make buildings
which are lower than the teak trees and
to insert them in this landscape for a
campus for the this amazing man Ratan
Tata who studied architecture Cornell
and who's a kind of great patron of the
Arts and an amazing human being who owns
this particular company as well as he
owns another 50 companies in India this
company since we met them has gone from
thirty thousand two hundred eighty
thousand employees but this is very much
a campus and has really quite few people
on it and the odd thing about the image
is it looks sort of like a ruin in the
middle of the forest but it's actually
buildings that have been built in the
middle of the forest and the forest is
still there an early sketch showing a
sense of the plans these finger
buildings that move out into the
landscape these are particular trees
we're trying to save and we have saved
but there are many others that are here
an auditorium library at dining hall
work study spaces a black box theatre in
many many components classrooms but it
is really for writing software this is
it there are 1200 people working every
day another site early examples we
brought the contractor to the states to
see our work but we decided all of the
work would be Indian work so
many many sites and many different kinds
of materials and India to make sure that
they could do it this is a their first
attempt at stair getting the tread
risers right it didn't work out very
well over here is that you said maybe
you could try that one again and they
are they're getting it amazing so we
left the failure and then we made the
corrected piece needed that for
virtually every one of them and they
very willingly once they could see how
to make it right they just started doing
it it's amazing this is the overall
image of the campus you our idea is that
you drop your power and stay away from
the campus park 600 cars in the low
grade here this is the mechanical plant
but everything else is by foot and as
many spaces it can be not
air-conditioned as possible and not
air-conditioned but you have to walk
from every building to every other
building under cover out of doors so
their paths that go through the
building's this way and this way the
site slopes 30 feet from here to here
there are two old houses that will keep
and restore so this is a just a sort of
vignette of the entryway there's a very
big canopy which has been cast in
concrete and will be clad in china tile
and that's at the entry this is a roof
of the canopy there's another quart of
oil just as this divot goes up and it's
covered with China Kyle as a protection
this will also be covered in Chinatown
so you'll get off undercover and the
breezes will continue to be saved from
the wind and the
from the Sun and the rain we're using
this wonderful stone from from Madurai
which is called Kashmir white they said
you know this is terrible done so we
went to the quarian learned about the
stone and we have fantastic stone for
mother I Hall 60 mm thick everything is
lifted by a chain hoist by people going
like this all of these stairs are
actually out of doors and they will be
clad in stone but the concrete will be
explored supposable or that so everett
there i think 18 different stairways
that are actually both fire stairs in
these cases they're actually out of
doors and walk to a carrison and walk
out looking into the landscape the
stairs is here here here here and those
are our stairs become passageways
between buildings and in the landscape
so this is a one of the larger
courtyards rendering and here you can
see they form the concrete and actually
in a later shot it's now being clad in
stone construction those a little slowly
there so they're pouring concrete by
turning it on their heads in Nashville
small amounts but I mean in many ways
that's how buildings get built without
turn down we decided that the changing
topography should leave the bottoms of
all buildings at one level and that this
dotted area is the air conditioned area
this is the non air conditioned area we
wanted to make sure that no son I will
instruct the floor of an interior air
conditioned space and for the most part
gave filtered light and and used the
natural convection that can occur we
have a fountain and a little bit of air
in the air through and having now that
it's far enough along everyone
understands this does work so these are
very big constructed berms the rendering
and he ran so 30 feet tall protecting
the tree they will be fully planted and
finds himself over that
it has that out of doors undercover all
at our circulation so the rendering this
is an outdoor passageway everything here
is out of doors one of these outdoor
stairways all of this will be clad in
stone for the horizontal surfaces coated
the exterior planning is that is the
kind of your life here we are walking on
a raised either below below this canopy
or on the top of this chemical which is
a cover canopy going from one building
to the next as you experience the
buildings in the land they're basically
only two stories tall so as towers come
up they begin to divorce this so that
raised walkway will be clad in a carved
stone this a traditional jelly and then
here they are working on the pedals for
the raised walkway they carved from both
sides and now they're starting to use
CNC cutting but they were still finish
it by hand when we began they were it
was totally all done by hand and that
was only about six years ago so this is
a panel maker will take the panel and
say is this good enough what's good
nothin ear this is the back side of this
panel so one side is carved and the
other side of the curb and they mesh in
the middle you get that complex pattern
it's it that will be about will be
literally 150 feet long passage 12 years
they also have recreational facilities
so this early drawing of a pool thinking
about the pool at cranbrook but this one
being always open to the sky and open to
the outdoors but with it cover overhead
allowing water during the monsoon to
come into the pool hair is quite many
little spaces it's very deep down here
will be clad on a stone on the inside
and plan
with stone on on the inside of the space
concrete will be expressed in it isn't
that much of the work as it meets the
ground there also sunken courtyards
because as Todd said the ground Rises so
as the building sort of plows into the
ground there are courtyards that are
much lower and one of the things we
thought was so interesting in ahmedabad
where the stepwells these wells which
cut down into the ground and we're both
places at certain times for certainly
water but also I think very social
places very cool places so this is one
of those outdoor meeting spaces that all
of those spaces out of doors everything
this is undercover these are the
workstations these will be long sheets
of blast that enable those to the air
conditioned but the amount of exterior
public walkway is extraordinary people
are expected to take their kittens
outside in and to eat in the walkways so
we're working with a group called
woman's weave and taking traditional
ECOT patterns and enlarging them the
fabric of the threads are died at a
central location and then distributed so
women can work at home to create these
home well hanging this is the first of
118 of the different one then there are
these pooling courtyards these are the
work stations that have different
communities and and this is one of these
channels of air that brings the air down
into the spaces deeply shaded a fountain
at the bottom and then this air tube is
the casting for the air tube it's there
it's in a pretty amazing we know that it
looked like that and keep it so this is
the form there me using that form and
then this is the typical roof in that
campus so that's the China tell that
covers
roof were then covering the interior of
that light tube as the canopies in the
broken china town so this is one of
those faces every bit of the space
through here is an outdoor space but it
brings in a diffuse but very beautiful
light that changes with the course of
the day and this is the last image
showing the farm work for the fountain
that will be below light ocular yeah we
wanted there and throughout this campus
but it's amazing and when the work is
good there's a cannon not only is their
common quality but there's a kind of
spiritual quality to the work so Billy
will read the last quote of the talk by
Reinhold Niebuhr nothing that is worth
doing can be achieved in our lifetime
and therefore we must be saved by hope
nothing which is true or beautiful or
good makes complete sense in any
immediate context of history therefore
we must be saved by faith and nothing we
do however virtuous can be accomplished
alone and therefore we must be saved by
love thank